another funeral another victim of ebola
this time in Guinea the disease has now
claimed almost 5 a half thousand lives
while it's not clear how this victim
contracted it a group of scientists have
identified a common source primates
they've developed a highly contagious
vaccine containing antigens they hope
will stop the spread between humans and
animals we're coming from a human aspect
because we want to prevent them gorillas
being a transmission Source into humans
and the the conservationist including
say World Wildlife Fund are working from
a conservation aspect because it's such
a threat to the survival of these
animals fruit bats are permanent hosts
to the Ebola virus and can indirectly
infect humans through the food chain
bush meat is a vital free source of
protein that keeps many poor families
alive periodically maybe they'll touch
the some fruit saliva goes onto the
fruit it drops onto the floor a gorilla
picks it up or a chimpanzee and it it
kills them they then get taken back to a
village they are butchered and now you
have a potential outbreak of the Bowa
Jarvis and his colleagues still need to
conduct clinical trials before the viral
Vector can be used in the ape population
despite the rapid spread of the disease
across West African countries time might
be on their side the current virus now
that's causing the the outbreak in
Western Africa has only changed uh by
about 3% from the one that was causing
the disease back in 2004 so I don't
think we need to be worried that this is
a rapidly mutating virus that's evading
the immune response reducing the threat
of Ebola crossing over to humans has
proved one of medicine's biggest
challenges in decades but removing Apes
from the transmission chain could be a
solution that will save
lives
while